hunderttausende gefälschte corona
impfpässe sind in deutschland im umlauf
dahinter steckt eine mafia die diese
ausweise für 350 euro in geheimen
internetforen anbietet aber wer genau
steckt dahinter wir haben die impfpass
mafia aufgespürt
beginnen wollen wir heute abend mit
diesem gelben latten hier was ist
eigentlich los in deutschland dass
menschen bereit sind für so einen
impfpass 3 400 euro zu zahlen denn
hunderttausende dieser gefälschten
corona impfpässe sind in deutschland
mittlerweile im umlauf aber wer genau
steckt dahinter und was haben kriminelle
arabische clans damit zu tun unsere
reporter jörg völkerling sascha baumann
und stefan sander haben verdeckt im
umfeld der impfpass mafia recherchiert
nürnberg vergangenen montagabend über
4000 sogenannte spaziergänger
marschieren durch die altstadt
protestieren dort gegen impfpflicht und
bewohner maßnahmen bild reporter jörg
völkerling ist für achtung fanden dort
[Musik]
die impfpflicht sie wollen keine
versuchskaninchen sollen und rufen
freiheit freiheit und genau hier wird
uns auch ganz unverhohlen ein falscher
infos und ein falsches master test
angeboten
als sei es das normalste auf der welt
gibt sich ein mann als impfpass welcher
zu erkennen schlechtes gewissen
fehlanzeige
durch eine spende vom an den arzt rennt
uhr bis gar nicht
doch auch im ständigen ist
wenn ich damit kritisieren wie die milch
damit sich die stadt nürnberg
von daher bin ich ins kino kann oder den
passionen
[Musik]
der mann sich wichtig machen oder wird
unser reporter am ende einen impfpass in
der hand halten
[Applaus]
ortswechsel impfgegner kriminelle ärzte
viele haben das lukrative impfpass
geschäft für sich entdeckt seit
vergangenen mittwoch ermittelt die
staatsanwaltschaft berlin gegen eine
ärztin im nobelviertel grunewald
millionen teure villen beste umgebung
hier soll es in einer hausarztpraxis
einen illegalen handel mit den
zertifikaten gegeben habe in einer der
villen hinter mir befindet sich die
praxis von gisela f sie soll zum
stückpreis von 180 euro mindestens 200
menschen gefälschte impfpässe besorgt
haben und diese so aufbereitet haben
dass diese problemlos in einer apotheke
digitalisiert werden konnten ich habe
mich hier in der nachbarschaft umgehört
immer wieder gab es aufregung denn das
verkehrschaos war groß wenn gisela auf
ihre praxis offen gehabt hat standen die
leute offenbar bisher zur straße
schlange und unter ihnen auch
mutmaßliche mitglieder arabischer groß
grenz geriet in die fänge von diesem
clients wurde sie möglicherweise
gezwungen gefälschte pässe auszustellen
das praxisschild ist inzwischen vom zaun
abmontiert die praxis geschlossen wir
fragen bei der staatsanwaltschaft berlin
nach die vergangenen mittwoch die razzia
gemeinsam mit dem lka durchgeführt hat
natürlich schwieriger aufwendige
ermittlungen werden durchsucht und
beweismittel sichergestellt da muss
jetzt natürlich erst mal gesehen werden
welche fälle überhaupt davon umfasst zu
inwieweit besteht ein verdacht im
zusammenhang mit kriminellen clans es
gibt gewisse persönliche und
geschäftliche
hinweise in richtung organisierte
kriminalität denen wir nachgehen
die engpässe mit den co wird impfungen
ein begehrtes gut online sollen sie ganz
einfach zu bekommen sein tagelang
recherchieren wir nach einem impfpass in
einschlägigen telegramm gruppen
zahlenden währungen die auch im online
spiele bereich genutzt werden
stimmkarten paysafe karten und sind am
ende 400 euro ärmer wir haben jetzt
mehrere tage in diversen foren auf
telekom recherchiert die allianz weg
unverhohlen im namen tragen cupid
impfpass steht da
350 euro werden für ein zertifikat mit
drei impfungen aufgerufen bezahlt werden
soll mit bitcoin oder virtuellen
währungen und tatsächlich haben wir bei
mehreren versuchen die wertguthaben
geschickt codes übermittelt doch sobald
das geschehen war verstummten die kanäle
wurden gelöscht ein impfpass landete nie
bei uns im briefkasten
betrüger betrügen betrüger das ist der
status ende januar 2022 die betrogenen
haben kein interesse dem pass anbieter
anzuzeigen weil sie sonst wegen
versuchter kunden fälschung dran wären
und die im spaß anbieter müssen gar
nichts mehr liefern weil sie nach
erfolgter anzahlung über völlig anonyme
zahlungswege einfach ihren kanal
schließen und die nutzer blockieren
amtsgericht nürnberg ortstermin bei
einem prozess gegen einen mutmaßlichen
impfpass fälscher
[Musik]
am 21.11 vergangenen jahres sogar von
antalya nach nürnberg und legte dort den
beamten einen gefälschten etwas vor er
wurde überführt angeklagt wegen
urkundenfälschung doch sein platz im
sitzungssaal 33 des nürnberger
amtgerichts blieb leer verurteilt wurde
er trotzdem
es wird zum heutigen verfahren nicht
gekommen die staatsanwaltschaft hat
einen strafbefehl beantragt 70
tagessätze á 40 euro und dieser
strafbefehl wurde dann auch vom gericht
erlassen man geht hier von einer
fälschung von gesundheits zeugnissen aus
das war noch das alte recht also auch
eine strafbarkeit nach dem vorherigen
recht da es aber hier bei einer behörde
vorgelegt wurde ist das auch
unproblematisch
das hessische landeskriminalamt hat eine
spezielle ermittlungsgruppe ins leben
gerufen ihr ziel der kampf gegen die
impfpass mafia die zahl der fälschungen
ist seit oktober 2021 sprunghaft
angestiegen als in hessen kann ich sagen
sind wir in einer noch unteren
vierstelligen anzahl
ermittlungsverfahren die wir jetzt
konstatieren wobei ich sagen kann dass
wir insbesondere seit oktober und gerade
november eine sprunghafte falls an
entwicklung haben das hat verschiedene
ursachen primär natürlich die die wir
haben nur ein straftatbestand die zweite
ja sozusagen notwendigkeit für viele
betroffene war zweifelsfrei dass die den
zugang zum öffentlichen leben eben nur
noch mit der entsprechenden impfnachweis
spätestens seit november dezember
möglich war stichwort zweig zweig plus
und die entsprechenden erfordernisse
wenn ich noch am öffentlichen leben
teilnehmen möchten all das hat eben zu
dieser explosion geführt und das sehen
wer tatsächlich auch in den fall
zurück in nürnberg werden wir den
impfpass fälscher von der korona demo
wieder treffen und wird er uns
tatsächlich einen impfpass besorgen wir
sind gespannt und tatsächlich tauchte
man auf erklärt uns sogar erneut seine
beweggründe
das ist das erstellen eines
schriftstücks ist meine meinung eine
urkunde wir nicht fähig wäre ein
bestehendes schriftstück von einer
behörde oder einem arzt ja was ich dann
ab ändere so dass ich es braucht man
sagt der arzt das habe ich dir niemals
so ausgestellt
deswegen
gibt's den arzt auch nett und die
verfahren sind zwar anhängig aber die
frage ist werden die verurteilt dadurch
mann hat in einer nacht und nebelaktion
eingesetzt gemacht wo kunden fälschung
die frage ist die frage ist ist es
urkundenfälschung es ist keine urkunde
ich kann das kaufen wir nehmen mit
wissen der polizei den impfpass entgegen
fahren nach stuttgart ins
robert-bosch-krankenhaus klinikchef
professor marc dominik alscher soll
unseren gefälschten impfpass bewerten
ich habe jetzt einen falschen impfpass
mitgebracht den haben wir uns in
nürnberg geschafft und es wäre mal
wichtig zu wissen wie ein profi den
blick darauf hat was er da erkennen kann
ok also zunächst was ich sehe es ist ein
offizieller impfpass das passt was
auffallend ist dass der aufkleber hier
sehr professionelles der
wahrscheinlichen aufkleber eines
krankenhauses würde mir erst mal viel
vertrauen schaffen weil das nicht üblich
ist meistens sind die handschriftlich
ausgefüllt dann gehe ich auf die zeit
das sehen sie hier auch wo der
rohner impfstoff dargestellt ist da
schaue ich mir die impf abstände an die
passen von der intervall von intervallen
ganz wichtig ist sind diese weißen
aufkleber mit jedem impfstoff kommt so
ein aufkleber wo sie die chargennummer
haben und diesen vorhanden man müsse nur
handschriftliche eintragungen also das
ist auch vertrauen schaffen dann schaue
ich mir die unterschriften an diesen
gleich sehen auch gut aus stempel passt
dazu das einzige was auffällt dass die
lebenslange arzt nummer nicht auf dem
stempel erfasst es was oft der fall ist
nicht zwingend sein muss ein privatarzt
davon stempel zu gestalten also ich muss
ganz klar sagen auf den ersten blick
würde ich ganz sagen das passt alles und
wenn ich apotheker wer bin ich mir fast
sicher würden sie ihren qr code bekommen
kriminell werden um sich einen falschen
impfpass zu erschleichen und dafür auch
noch 100 euro ausgeben dafür hat der
klinikchef professor alter kein
verständnis ich habe wenig verständnis
dafür die impfung ist so harmlos und
warum er sich das nicht einfach geben
lässt bei den staat muss ich den ganzen
aufwand die kosten umgekehrt ist es aber
auch verantwortungslos weil wenn ich mit
dem gefälschten dokument zum beispiel
räumlichkeiten wo andere menschen davon
ausgehen dass man jemand geimpftes ich
übertrage eventuell die krankheit könnte
ich menschen gefährden die dann wirklich
massiv komplikationen bekommen sofern
verantwortungslos stuttgart wiesbaden
berlin nürnberg nach langer recherche
halten wir tatsächlich einen gefälschten
impfpass in den händen wer also
kriminell werden möchte er wird es auch
schaffen doch mit gewisser
wahrscheinlichkeit auch die volle härte
des gesetzes zu spüren bekommen
[Musik]
und schauen sie mal das hier das ist ja
der gefälschte impfpass die
chargennummern von den impfungen die
hier drin kleben die sind aber echt und
zwar von menschen die echt geimpft
wurden und danach sich gemeinsam mit
ihrem impfpass im internet gepostet
haben bei facebook bei instagram bei
twitter und dort genau hat der fälscher
dann sich die nummer hergezogen und die
hier in unseren gefälschten pass
eingetragen das sollte man also
unbedingt nicht tun dieser gefälschte
impfpass der kompliziert bei uns in
einen gesicherten safe bis wir ihn dann
an die behörden übergeben